on est au milieu des champs à london en
ontario
à deux pas du dôme bindi c'est un des
plus grands simulateur de tornado monde
durant une tornade les ventilateurs tout
autour créé le tourbillon de vent et ce
au plafond créé la section
c'est ce quartier de darwin qui sera
soumis au test
une trentaine de maisons au total
l'objectif est de mesurer les forces
maximale qu'elles vont subir
adam levine en septembre 2018
quand la tornade de toucher terre les
ventes ont atteint jusqu'à 265
kilomètres à l'heure les dommages ont
été énormes
le but c'est de bâtir un modèle qui
perdra tester différentes configurations
de bâtiments puis et d'anticiper les
pertes roccat tornade
la tornade simuler se forme sous nos
yeux sur les maisons une série de
minuscules capteurs enregistrent les
moindres variations de pression sur les
murs et les toits oui non les coins du
poisson des zones critiques mais le
centre du toit pour un l'être aussi en
soumettant tout un quartier aux tests
plutôt qu'un seul édifice
on vise aussi à mieux comprendre comment
chacun d'eux affecte la dispersion du
vent c'est le comportement des bâtiments
face à ce tourbillon de à long terme les
résultats des tests pourraient aussi
mener au développement de bâtiments plus
résistants face aux tornades ici andré
bernard à radio-canada à montréal